مخيم تول كرم عاش اصعب الاوقات واكثرها
دمويه حوالي 44 ساعه من الحصار المطبق على
المخيم تخللوا مداهمات واسعه للمنازل
تدميرها بشكل كامل تخريب كل محتوياتها
تفجير عدد منها اضافه لمئات حالات
الاعتقال والاحتجاز والتنكيل بالناس خلال
احتجازهم وتدمير كل مكونات البنيه
التحتيه وين ما توقع العين بتلاقي الدمار
والخراب في كل ركن ما ضل فعل شارع ولا
طريق ما دمره جيش الاحتلال والمحال
التجاريه كان لها نصيب كبير من هال
التدمير حوالي 1000 بيت في مخيم تولكر
تعرض
للمداهمة اللي حولها جيش الاحتلال لمركز
تحقيق
ميداني وفي مخيم نور شمس الصوره مماثله
دمار هائل في كل شيء حتى انه بعض المنازل
والازق تحولت لركام وحطام ه المنطقه هي
جزء من حاره المنشيه احدى ابرز حارات مخيم
نور شمس اللي بتتعرض للعدوان خلال
الاقتحامات مكان وقوف الجرافه تماما كان
في جزء من احدى المنازل بسد ه المنطقه
ولكن جرافات احتلال قامت بتدميرها بشكل
كامل وفتحت طريقين على بعض وهذا كله مجرد
لمحه
[موسيقى]